[Music]
a great
orbiting telescope floats serenely in
the black
collecting light from the heavens above
it adjusts its field of view slightly
turning away from the nearby stars
and peers deeper into the darker reaches
of the night sky
beneath it the planet turns its white
clouds
swirling serenely in the faint stellar
glow and positioned as it is
above the turbulent atmosphere this
telescope
has an unrivalled view of the cosmos
closest just a few light years away are
individual stars
unique suns just like the one now hiding
out of sight behind the planet
they cluster thickest in a wide bright
band that cuts the blackness in two
this is the galactic plane looking along
it
is to look to the center of the galaxy
some 100
000 light years away and the galaxy is
an immense
flattened spiral home to 400 billion
suns but the little telescope turns its
gaze away
from this blinding light looking up
above the galactic plain
the stars are more sparsely scattered
but the sky is lit instead by
dim multi-coloured smears each is a
galaxy in its own right
containing billions of stars that burn
just as brightly as those nearby
but whose intensity is masked by sheer
distance
mapping the positions of these diverse
galaxies the orbiting telescope sees a
few dozen cluster loosely together in a
local group
deeper into the blackness even dimmer
smudges hint at more distant
galactic clusters with enough time the
telescope can map these too
finding that they cling together in even
vaster
superclusters several hundred million
light years across
and bordered by gaping black voids where
no galaxies are to be found at all
and at the very edge of its magnified
site the instrument glimpses
the very edge of the observable universe
45 billion light years away
thus the structure of the universe is
revealed in the simple curved mirror
of an orbiting telescope but this
instrument
does not orbit the earth
it is a machine of another world
orbiting an
alien planet that itself orbits an alien
sun
the bright streak of the galactic plane
is not that of the milky way
and the nearby galaxies are also foreign
and unfamiliar
our home planet is somewhere else in
that extraterrestrial instrument
sites although it would be almost
impossible to pinpoint
there are no landmarks in the
large-scale structure of the cosmos
no major differences from place to place
that help us find our way
the universe looks surprisingly similar
wherever you happen to be looking from
it has broadly the same temperature
and the same lumpy structure of dense
superclustered galaxies and hollow voids
looked at from an omnipotent external
point of view where entire galactic
clusters are reduced to mere points of
light
the cosmos is remarkably uniform
but how did this come to be
how could such distant parts of the
universe separated by tens of billions
of light years
be so similar places so distant
that they could never ever have had any
contact
it is a mystery that has plagued our
accepted cosmological histories
since they were written a gaping hole in
our understanding
is our story of the origin of the
universe incomplete
or is this evidence of uniformity merely
a freak occurrence a bizarre coincidence
localized to our view
of the infinite cosmos to truly
investigate this mystery
cosmological detectives must take an
explosive journey
right back to the very beginning we must
probe improbable connections between the
minuscule quantum world
and the gigantic realm of superclusters
and open our minds to the even wider
even weirder
possibility of a nested multiverse
hiding within our very own cosmos
we must ask what put the bang
into the big bang or if the bang
should even be there at all
[Music]
about 13.8 billion years ago
the universe began
we don't know for sure how it happened
what it looked like or how it behaved
during its very first moments but all of
the evidence we have suggests that
at the beginning it was very very small
and very very hot calculations by the
physicist and priest george lemaitre
in the 1920s revealed that we live in an
expanding universe
which logically must have begun much
smaller than it is today
subsequent observations have bolstered
his mathematical viewpoint
the light from distant galaxies appears
more red than it should do
as if the wavelengths themselves have
been stretched
the further those galaxies are the more
red they appear
so the faster they are receding such a
pattern could only arise if the entire
cosmos were expanding
and had been since the beginning of time
thanks to the finite speed of light
those distant far reaches of the
observable universe are also
gaping windows into the distant past and
they too
bear the marks of a smaller hotter
beginning
based on this startling agreement of
mathematical theory and highly precise
observations
the so-called big bang has become the
most widely accepted
theory for the origin of our universe
but there is a problem
there are many features of our modern
universe that don't
fit with a simplistic expanding big bang
origin story not least an infinitely
small infinitely dense and infinitely
hot beginning violating
all known laws of physics but there is
more
there are features of the cosmos today
that are very hard to explain
if the universe had simply been
expanding at a steady rate
all this time thorns in the side of the
big bang theory
that threaten to bring it all crashing
back down
the first is known as the horizon
problem
an alien observer looking at the
universe from tens of billions of light
years away would see a cosmos almost
indistinguishable from our own in
particular
the background radiation which raises
the average temperature of space to a
few degrees above absolute zero
wherever in the observable universe one
happens to observe it
the chances of this being the case under
a simplistic big bang regime are
vanishingly small
the only way that the temperature of the
cosmos can be so homogenized
is if all parts of that cosmos were in
contact
long enough for them to reach
equilibrium
a cold room with a single heat source in
one corner
will eventually reach an equilibrium
temperature as the thermal energy
is distributed evenly throughout the
space
but expanding space time does not allow
for homogenization on such large scales
energy can only be exchanged at the
speed of light and there has not been
enough time since the beginning of the
universe for equilibrium to be reached
there is no way that opposite sides of
the universe can trade energy
because they are beyond one another's
visible
horizon they are not as scientists say
in causal contact running the
cosmological expansion backwards we find
that parts of the night sky just
one degree apart would have been beyond
each other's reach at the time
the background radiation was baked into
the universe
how then did the universe get to be so
homogenous such an observation seems to
require that the cosmological beginnings
were finely tuned
with remarkable homogeneity from the
very start
yet the laws of physics and of
statistics suggest that such fine-tuning
is vanishingly unlikely a second
puzzling phenomenon
seems to require this unlikely
fine-tuning too
known as the flatness problem it is
concerned with the intangible curvature
of space-time
the fabric of space as einstein defined
it in his theories of general relativity
is distorted by massive objects but
if concentrations of mass are
responsible for curving space-time
then all of the mass in the universe
must curve space-time as well
depending on the density of the universe
as a whole the shape of that curvature
and the long-term evolution of the
cosmos
varies considerably if it is high then
the cosmological mass
creates a spherical space-time and the
gravitational attraction between all the
matter in the universe will eventually
slow down expansion
and reverse it if the density of the
universe is low
space will have an open hyperbolic shape
and the gravity between matter will not
be enough to stop it expanding
forever and between these two
alternatives
there is a third possibility a flat
space-time
with just the right density for
expansion to slow to a stop
only after infinite time this
flat universe is a precarious balance
between a cosmos that is too dense
and one that is not dense enough both of
which
are much more likely outcomes than the
knife edge
intermediate and yet when astronomers
measure the density of the observable
universe
they find out that this most unlikely of
outcomes is in fact
our reality to remarkably high precision
our modern universe appears to be
utterly invariably
flat there is no reason why it should be
so
any toss of the cosmos creating coin is
almost infinitely more likely to produce
one of the other alternatives
but in hours the coin appears to have
landed
on its edge was there something special
about the universe's origins that set
the stage for such
precise balance or are our origin
stories
fundamentally incorrect
and one further conundrum needles the
big bang theory of universal expansion
despite extensive searches on a variety
of scales
there appear to be no monopoles at all
in the observable cosmos a monopole is
hypothesized to be just
half of a traditional magnet an isolated
origin or ending
of magnetic field lines without a
corresponding partner elsewhere in space
we are well accustomed to dipole magnets
with north and south poles and a
magnetic field that flows between them
they are most simply represented by
schoolroom bar magnets
wherever we look there is never just a
north
or south sitting alone
this is a problem because there is no
fundamental reason why there shouldn't
be any monopoles not only that but our
current understanding of the universe's
earliest moments
suggests that the cosmos should be in
fact flooded by them
but in reality we find none at all
together the horizon problem the
flatness problem and the lack of
monopoles in the modern universe
combine to cool the entire big bang
theory into question
how did the universe end up so
homogenous when it was too large for
temperatures to equilibrate
how did the density of matter come to be
resting on the near impossible knife
edge that renders space-time flat
and finally what happened to all the
monopoles
these are damning testaments in the case
against the big bang
and ever since the evidence was
discovered cosmologists have scrambled
to find an alibi
some explanation that could yet save
the big bang history from its demise
in a small low house in west menlo park
at the south of san francisco bay alan
guth
worked late into the night the
californian breeze
stirred the pages on guth's desk
uncovering sheet after sheet
filled with fine spidery writing of
equations overwritten with annotations
and overwritten again with wild thoughts
and speculation
guth was a smart man but he reflected he
was born at the wrong time
part of the baby boomer generation he
found himself among fierce competition
for academic work at every turn
in any other time his dedication and
insight into particle physics would have
almost automatically earned him tenure
at his pick of ivy league institutions
and yet here he was
in yet another temporary post working
late
in an increasingly desperate effort to
get ahead
this time guth's work had brought him to
the stanford linear accelerator
for a year to investigate the
hypothesized grand unification of forces
at the beginning of the universe
and the mystery of the missing monopoles
his calculations were nonsensical to all
but the most involved particle physicist
but that night he found himself in a
flow that seemed to lay out the
mysteries of the universe for him to
understand
in an entirely new way as the breeze
curled the corners of his workings he
was struck
with a spectacular realization
a solution that seemed to demolish all
objections to the big bang itself
the missing monopoles the horizon
problem the flatness problem
all solved if he was right
then this was an elegant cosmological
thesis to rival that of the metra
and guth would never have to worry about
finding work
again
but guth's late night revelation was far
from the first attempt to smooth the
rough edges of the big bang theory
back in the early 1930s father of the
theory georges le metre
had put forward a suggestion himself by
now known as the famous belgian
scientist and a leader in cosmological
physics
his remarkable observations on the
beginning of the universe had made him
a scientific celebrity but lemaitre did
not rest on his laurels
despite being praised by the catholic
church for his apparent demonstration of
a beginning
lemaitre himself did not see it as such
the universe was like a phoenix
born living growing old and diminishing
in flames
only to birth a brand new entity from
the ashes
the metra's phoenix universe and its
various incarnations as a
cyclic cosmology a big bounce
would help to resolve some of the
inconsistencies in the big bang story
by repeatedly living and dying cycling
between expansion contraction and
expansion again
there is ample opportunity for the
universe to reach thermal equilibrium
so that today after how many rebirths
space
itself appears utterly homogenous
the horizon problem solved
only this theory raises even more
questions
had our universe really lived and died
countless times before the beginning of
time
then there would be a record of it in
time itself
the arrow of time is driven forward by
the inevitable increase in entropy
in increasing statistical disorder from
one moment
to the next so if our current universe
was just the latest in a long line of
phoenix universes
then entropy would have kept on
increasing over all of those hidden
lifetimes
the disorder of the current universe
therefore would be so high that no
structure could possibly assemble
and persist the phoenix would live on
but each time it would be born older and
older
until the life it leads is really no
life at all
other solutions have been proposed over
the years to try and account for the
various irregularities in the metro's
cosmological history
in 1969 a professor at the university of
maryland
charles misner explored what he called
the mix
master universe so named after a popular
brand of kitchen mixer
his idea was that the early universe
went through a chaotic
oscillation and that this random and
unpredictable motion
like that of dough in a mixer would
inevitably lead to a homogeneous
well-mixed cosmos but the mathematics of
such a universe are fiendishly and
off-puttingly complex
and still the issues of flatness and
monopoles
are hard to explain
[Music]
so it was a decade later that alan guth
in a moment of divine
late night inspiration hit upon another
much simpler possibility one that
promised to solve the mystery of the
missing monopoles
but also addressed the wider flatness
and horizon problems
in turn
what if he supposed in the earliest
moments after the big bang
the universe had undergone a period of
massive
accelerated exponential expansion
before slowing down to its more moderate
speed today
he saw that such an expansion could
happen naturally at the end of the grand
unification epoch
as a result of energy transformations as
the individual fundamental forces
split from the greater whole so when the
universe was just a trillion trillion
trillionth of a second old
space would have started to expand
exponentially
exponential increases start out modestly
but have the capacity to get
very large very quickly one apocryphal
tale
tells of a ruler wishing to reward the
indian inventor of
chess and asking him to name his price
for such a
wondrous new game the inventor asked for
wheat
one grain on the first chessboard square
two on the next
four on the next then eight sixteen and
so on
doubling the amount of wheat for each of
the sixty-four squares on the chessboard
scoffing at the apparently meager
payment for such a great invention
the ruler readily agreed but his court
treasurers
soon realised the problem by the time
the board was filled
there would be nearly 18 and a half
quintillion
wheat grains to pay more than 2 000
times
modern annual production and so
the exponential expansion of space saw
the cosmos get very large
very quickly in around 100 billionth of
a second
the universe doubled in size around 90
times
such an increase would be equivalent to
expanding a single red blood cell
10 microns across to a gigantic disc
the size of our galaxy more than 100
000 light years in diameter
in reality though the early universe
started out much smaller than any cell
or indeed any atom in our body various
models disagree on the precise
dimensions but this massive expansion
saw the cosmos stretch from a speck
smaller than a proton to a respectable
roughly
grapefruit sized universe this
happened faster than the speed of light
a technicality that is possible in this
case because relativistic constraints
only apply to movements
within the cosmos not to the expansion
of the cosmos as a whole alan guth
described this explosive period
the first real change in the appearance
of the universe
as inflation and suddenly with this new
inflationary defendant on the stand
things finally started to fall into
place
for the early universe
for one inflation seemed to solve the
problem of the missing monopoles
the physics of the grand unification of
forces at the beginning of the universe
required that monopoles be created in
their droves when the strong force
became distinct this happened in a tiny
early universe a mere fraction of a
second old
and little more than a plank length
across
enter inflation and the near
instantaneous expansion of the cosmos
including the mysterious monopoles sees
them suddenly
and violently separated from one another
like chocolate chips
embedded in an expanding loaf of bread
today
after billions of years of expansion
following that initial burst
space has become so large and the
monopoles so far separated
that we don't see them simply because
there are none
within our observational reach in a
similar way this spectacularly rapid
inflation helps to address the horizon
problem and the flatness problem
in all likelihood there were massive
differences in temperature
of the post big bang universe but just
as inflation distributed the chocolate
chip
monopoles of the universe so it expanded
all other elements within it too
the temperature differences of that
early nano cosmos were near
instantaneously flung apart
but we don't see these stranded
variations
our observable slice of the cosmos is
only part of the greater
more inhomogeneous whole the limits of
the speed of light permit
us only to see one small patch of the
pre-inflationary universe
that was in thermal equilibrium with
itself how similar
or different it is to the rest beyond
our horizon
we cannot tell indeed one study in 2011
calculated the true size of the universe
as being 250 times
the size of our observable section
that is seven trillion light years
across
and this limited view of the vast cosmos
also offers the solution to the flatness
problem
it is vanishingly unlikely that our
cosmos has the precise critical density
of matter within it to render space-time
flat
but with inflation in the mix it does
not need to
the universe is flat as far as we can
see
but we are only seeing a small inflated
section of the greater hole
thanks to inflation our local area was
made so big
so quickly that all we see is flat
plains
as far as the light speed horizon take a
ball
and scale it up to the size of the earth
and even though
you know the overall structure is curved
your view
from the surface will always be flat so
with a stroke the introduction of
inflation into the earliest moments of
the cosmos seems to destroy
any case against the big bang
from a single vantage point much of the
structure of the minute early universe
is simply stretched out of existence
all temperature variations exotic
particles and the very geometry of space
itself disappear and when inflation is
finally exhausted
a decillionth of a second later a
disembodied observer
would be left stranded in a cold empty
space
that it seemed so full mere moments
before
just a few meters away from the south
pole
the stilted scott arminson station
is illuminated by starlight alone
just a few weeks into the six-month long
antarctic night
the temperature has already dropped to
less than minus 50 degrees celsius
and the wind howls around the curved
building
from outside the station looks abandoned
but a faint mechanical were from the
gigantic telescope dish
gives away just the smallest sign of
life
and inside the heavily insulated control
room
only warm compared to the frigid night
outside
a small team of scientists huddle
in coats they are among just a few dozen
who have elected to stay through the
months of this endlessly dark
polar winter antarctic summers see the
south pole home to more than 200
but few would choose to brave the icy
dark isolation
of this eternal night but at nearly 3
000 metres above sea level
cold and dry air above the high
antarctic plateau
allows the microwave telescope they
control to scan
the deepest reaches of the cosmos with
unrivaled precision
precise enough they hope to find an
imprint
of inflation itself embedded in the
radiation that permeates all of space
as they pull their coats tighter about
them looking ahead to five more months
of this darkness
they wonder what they will find
because inflation for all its
problem-solving power is still yet to be
proven
unequivocally it has enjoyed widespread
press
and acceptance by the scientific
community being heralded as the first
moment that truly unites the small and
large scales of particle physics
and cosmology but it does more than that
it helps to explain how the very large
scale structures of the universe came
about
in the first place from the smallest
possible seeds
all of the stuff we see out there in
space ultimately results from an
imbalance of matter versus antimatter
mass versus vacuum
positive versus negative energy while
the large scale temperature of the
cosmos may be homogeneous
the distribution of stuff within it
certainly
is not huge galactic superclusters are
bordered by yawning voids containing
nothing at all on the scale we
experience it
our universe is one of contrast
but the origin of that contrast is not
clear
how did all this variety spontaneously
arise
from practically nothing at all
surprisingly it is in the tiny world of
quantum mechanics that a potential
solution
can be found on the smallest possible
scales quantum particles behave in
strange
and inexplicable ways one of these
curious behaviors is described by
heisenberg's uncertainty principle
in which quantum fluctuations
spontaneously create
and annihilate virtual particle pairs
with no recourse to cause and effect
the pre-inflationary universe was small
enough for such quantum effects to play
a major role for the first
minuscule fraction of a second and when
inflation began
the space containing those quantum
fluctuations
suddenly ballooned rendering them vast
beyond imagining
and sowing the seeds for the large scale
contrast we see today
from nothing at all structure was
created
alan guth himself described it as the
ultimate
free lunch
indeed seven years before guth's
spectacular realization
the physicist edward trion had proposed
the idea that the entire universe could
be created by one of these quantum
fluctuations in a vacuum
truly borne out of nothing in answer to
the question of why it happened
i offer the modest proposal that our
universe is simply one of those things
which happen from time to time
[Music]
but constructing more theories that fit
inflation is no true proof
that the original theory is correct what
is needed is unequivocal
observational evidence that this
explosive expansion really did occur
and that is what the antarctic
astronomers were searching for
in 2013
[Music]
with the bicep ii telescope pointing
deep into the south polar sky
they were probing the fine-scale nature
of the cosmic microwave background
for remnants of that ancient time known
as b-mode polarization
which they believed could only have been
created by universe-wrenching
forces of inflation and in march that
year
they finally had their result with great
excitement
scientists from harvard stanford caltech
and the university of minnesota
announced to the press that they had
found
their hallowed b modes created by
gravitational waves that rippled out
like shock waves from the blast of
cosmological inflation
it was a discovery worthy of a nobel
prize
the culmination of 35 years of theory
prediction
and experimentation but their joy
was short-lived as the months drew on
the scientists confidence in their
discovery waned
it appeared that inflation-induced
ripples in space-time were not the only
thing that could create
b-mode polarization cosmic dust
permeating the view of the south polar
sky had
it seemed a major and unavoidable effect
on the radiation they measured
so now they push up their sleeves and
prepare
to try again
other predictions for remnants left over
from cosmic inflation have also failed
to yield any tangible results
[Music]
in the early 1970s stephen hawking
investigated the possibility of
so-called primordial black holes
arising from gravitational anomalies in
the very early universe
less than a second after the big bang
once inflation took its place on the big
bang stage
it was found that cosmological inflation
could be an ideal mechanism for
generating
such primordial black holes not only
that
but what could appear today to us as an
ancient black hole
could in fact contain entire
baby universes born of differing rates
of inflation
and isolated from our own cosmos by the
limits of their observable universe
to the inhabitants of these baby
universes all would appear normal
from within they would exist within an
expanding cosmos much like our own
and believe that that was all there was
but to us
as omnipresent external observers we
are as gods beyond the plane of their
existence
able to see their bubble universe in its
entirety
yet the same light horizon that prevents
those inside from seeing out
also blocks our view through the looking
class
we cannot know whether these featureless
black holes contain a hyper-compressed
singular mass
or an entire living universe trapped
just out of reach it
is another mind-bending prospect that of
a nested multiverse lurking right
beneath our noses
but despite astronomers best efforts
peering into the blackness
the search so far goes unrewarded
we have not found any primordial black
holes
or baby universes inflation is on rocky
ground when it comes to its mechanism
too
although alan guth's theoretical model
suggested how
inflation started attempts to
characterize its cause within the
framework of particle physics
have thus far failed so the inflation
field is thought to be communicated by a
virtual particle
called the inflaton but so far
no inflation field and no inflaton
has been discovered but the science
is still young the higgs boson was only
discovered in 2012
nearly 50 years after it was first
proposed
perhaps an inflaton discovery sits just
over the horizon
or perhaps not
[Music]
[Applause]
american physicist paul steinhardt
raised a glass to the assembled revelers
in the bar for a moment all faces turned
towards him
and the cheer filled the room but as his
colleagues returned to their passionate
conversations
the music swelled and steinhardt was
left alone with his thoughts
in the crowded bar
today steinhardt's latest paper had just
been accepted for publication
and as was tradition at the university
of pennsylvania that meant the first
round of beers was on him
his latest paper was a great boon to the
university to cosmology and to the
exciting new theory
of inflation he didn't know it at the
time
but he would become one of the important
pioneers
responsible in part for the great early
success
of inflation theory and yet
even then steinhardt's mind
was troubled everything he and his
co-author had written in the paper was
true
and rigorous peer review had probed his
models thoroughly
but the implications of his work were
disturbing
to make inflation work they had to
choose their parameters
very very carefully if they didn't their
model cosmos
created twisted multiverses time and
time again
a seed of doubt took hold in his mind
and began to grow
today steinhardt has had a radical
change of heart
and is not shy about destroying that
which he
helped build inflation theory he says
has introduced more problems than it was
originally intended
to solve worse scientists are turning a
blind eye to the theory's failings
and are themselves failing to properly
scrutinize the concept
preferring instead to see it as an
incomprehensible
magic bullet inflation has been elevated
to an almost
religious status a faith that gives
cosmologists a comfortable peace of mind
against the unanswerable mysteries of
the universe
and has given rise to any number of
misinterpretations
and potential manifestations and so
the situation must be serious for one of
the theory's main proponents to become
its most
vocal opponent
and steinhardt is not the only inflation
apostate
they claim that there are now so many
different models of how inflation could
work and so many variables that can be
endlessly tweaked
that a true testable inflation theory
does not exist
like the pseudo-scientific assertions of
a creator
inflation has become undisprovable
steinhardt reiterates that inflation was
invoked as a way of avoiding having to
fine-tune the early conditions of the
universe
with inflation the earliest big bang
cosmos didn't have to be completely flat
geometry
and didn't need to be completely
homogeneous but the physics of inflation
now seem to require that same fine
tuning
in order to produce the universe we see
today analyzing the fine scale
observations of the cosmic background
radiation in 2013
steinhardt and his colleagues calculated
that there was less than one in a
googleplex charts of inflation producing
the precise pattern
imprinted in the universe inflation was
supposed to give us a smooth homogeneous
cosmos
but in all but the most choice of models
it produces a terrifying multiverse
of twisted knotted and in folded
space-time
inflation is in trouble but there is
nothing quite ready to take its place
alternative histories have been
suggested including a return to
lumetra's phoenix universe
if the entropy problem can be resolved
steinhardt himself is a proponent of a
return to this
big bounce cyclical concept perhaps the
currently constant speed of light is
blinkering us to the possibility that it
could have behaved differently
under bizarre big bang regimes perhaps
the birth of our universe is merely a
ripple in a higher dimensional bulk of
hyperspace
all of these alternatives have potential
but are rooted in physics we are not
able to understand
right now perhaps we never will
and perhaps that is why so many
scientists
still cling to inflation despite its
flaws
at least it can be described within the
realms of a cosmos
we can comprehend
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
i will see you next time